- [Kenny] Hey.
- Hey.
- [Kenny] Nice to meet you.
- Gary.
- Kenny Cousins.
- Real pleasure, Kenny.
- [Kenny] Same here.
- How are things?
- [Kenny] Great.
- Good man.
- [Kenny] Yeah.
- What's going on?
- [Kenny] Good Friday.
I wanted to finally
get some time on the books.
- I'm glad.
- [Kenny] Been here for just
over three and a half months.
- Awesome.
- [Kenny] Had my 90 day review,
two weeks ago.
- How'd it go?
- [Kenny] Great.
- Good.
What do you do?
- [Kenny] I'm an ACC
on Lisa and David's pod.
- Awesome.
- So I'm an ACC on Axe
and Dove Men's Care.
- How'd you get here?
- I got here, it's a long
story but I'll truncate it.
I heard about you
through Charlamagne's podcast
and I've been friends with
Tyler since Montclair days.
- No shit? You
grew up in Montclair?
- [Kenny] Yeah. We were
playing lacrosse together.
- I love it.
- [Kenny] He's
one grade above me.
And I saw that you guys
had moved into Hudson Yards
and I've been coming here
for another client upstairs
for my old company.
- Okay.
- [Kenny] And I did
PR at a small shop there.
And I saw that he had
posted the video of you
touring this
office and I was like
"Oh, my God. This is
the most amazing office."
I'd been here a few
times and so I hit up Ty
and I was like oh
you work at VaynerMedia?
I know nothing about it, I just
heard your name a few times.
- Understood.
- [Kenny] I looked into it,
I thought it was amazing.
The number of
people that worked here,
the amount of
services that you guys offered
and how quickly
you guys have grown.
And I've always
wanted to go somewhere
where I could see
myself in terms of
demographic, age and skill set.
- [Gary] Yeah.
- And so I talked to Ty,
and from there it was just like
feel in love instantly.
- [Gary] And
how's it been going?
- It's been great.
- [Gary] You enjoying it?
- My team's great.
I love being an ACC.
I love Lisa's pod.
Every individual
person on that team.
So many different strengths.
We just combine
and work together well.
It's really good.
Like not a bad thing here.
- [Gary] (laughs)
That's awesome, man.
That makes me so happy.
- I used to hate my old job but
I never get the
Sunday Scaries any more.
Straight up, I don't.
- [Gary] Makes me happy, man.
Where do you live? Jersey still?
- I moved from Jersey
to Brooklyn a year ago.
I live in Bed Stuy.
- [Gary] Very good.
And how you
thinking about your career?
Now you got a little
bit of the lay of the land,
like do you want
to be Lisa one day?
How do you think about things?
- [Kenny] So I have
account experience in my old job
and now here and
I've been thinking a lot.
I know I want to be on
the account rep for a while
just to get more
experience in my belt--
- Yep.
- [Kenny] in terms of business.
- Business, running shit.
- [Kenny] Yep.
- Mhmmm.
- [Kenny] I do have
aspirations of trying to
work on the Talent team.
- Oh, interesting.
- [Kenny] I've
always had kind of a
knack to working with talent.
Whether that was in
music or entertainment.
So, I think, you know,
if I'm hearing you right,
if you're thinking in
the mindset of 24, 36 months
on the account side by the time,
if that plays out and
you get those skills which
I recommend 'cause
you'll get them more there
than you would--
- [Kenny] Yeah.
-- the VaynerTalent thing is
going to be a monster by then.
I think there's just a million.
I'm sure the more you've
been doing homework on me
and things of that
nature, like, I don't know,
VaynerSports wasn't
supposed to be a thing.
- [Kenny] Mhmmm.
- You know?
VaynerMusic's not a thing
but the world thinks it is.
And it could be.
- [Kenny] Yeah.
- The entrepreneurial
vibe is deep here.
So, good, man.
- [Kenny] Yeah.
And also, I just want
to tell you something.
- Sure.
- [Kenny] On the train here,
I came from my
(inaudible) orientation
and I was like I
got 10 minutes to spare
so I was watching the
last 10 minutes of "Billions"
that TV show on Showtime.
- [Gary] Yep.
- And one of the characters,
one of the main characters
he's trying to
purchase a sports franchise.
And he happened to want
to purchase the Giants.
- [Gary] Okay.
- And he's on the phone with
another business partner
and he says that in America,
the royalty we knight
them with sports franchises.
- [Gary] I've heard,
I've been tweeted
a little bit
this morning about it.
- And I didn't know that it was
a thing before I heard that.
- [Gary] I'd never
heard that either.
- And I was like
things happen for a reason.
I knew I had my
meeting with you today.
(Gary laughs)
I heard this line.
- [Gary] That's so cool.
- So maybe he'll like this and
I was just like
this is perfect timing.
- [Gary] I can't
believe you said that.
I literally saw it this morning
or last night from some tweets.
I never thought about
that. It's interesting.
- [Kenny] Yeah. So I saw
that and I was like
my brain just blew up.
(Gary laughs)
You know, things
happen for a reason.
- For sure.
- [Kenny] Not a
coincidence, perfect timing.
- Anything I can answer for you?
- [Kenny] It was more
a personal question
back to the ACC rep,--
- Sure, sure.
- [Kenny] 'cause watching some
of the videos last night,
and specifically about telling
people what they should do
and not what they hope to do.
It's kind of like
be your true self.
- Yes.
- Knowing what you know now,
if you could go back
to your 25 years old--
- Yep.
- I'm 25, how would you
best conquer this ACC position?
'Cause I know it's brand new.
- The number one thing you
should do in this company,--
- [Kenny] Mhmmm.
- it's a little bit slightly
turned on what you just asked
but it's the absolute truth,
is you should get to know every
single person in this company.
- [Kenny] Yeah.
- With every ounce of my soul,
I'm telling you right now,
every one of your lunches
if you've got the time
and you're not on something
should be in the cafeteria and
you should literally
roll up and be like yo, hey.
- [Kenny] Yeah.
- It's everything.
- [Kenny] Mhmmm.
- People is the game.
- [Kenny] Yeah.
- Skills are
commoditized, my man.
- [Kenny] Mhmmm.
- The skills of taking
good notes, being organized,
being on time, being smart like
they're stunningly commoditized.
It's the relationships.
- [Kenny] Yeah.
- How'd you get here?
- [Kenny] Mhmmm.
- You played
lacrosse with somebody.
- [Kenny] Yeah.
- Relationships. Right.
- [Kenny] Mhmmm.
- You shake somebody's hand,
you become friends with them.
Do you understand what
VaynerMedia's gonna be?
VaynerMedia is going to be the
company that spits out
the digital ninjas
of the future world.
Somebody in this room
right now is literally the CEO
of Nike. Right now.
Somebody in this
office is the CEO of Nike.
- [Kenny] Yeah.
- 17 years from now.
Woulda been really
good if you said what's up?
That is the game.
Now, everybody's different.
Extrovert, introvert,
duh, duh, duh, right?
- [Kenny] Mhmmm.
- But that's it.
There's nothing
even remotely close.
Know everything about your team.
Ask them how you can help them.
Bring value to other people.
I do it now at this level.
- [Kenny] Yeah.
- When you're here,
that's (blows raspberry).
That's what people remember.
- [Kenny] Yeah.
- Give a fuck.
- [Kenny] Gotcha.
And then one more thing,
Ty said this morning also
he was like I've been hearing
good things and I was like
that's what keeps
the engines running.
And it's something so small but
I know you've said
in a lot of your videos
putting more
positive content out there.
- [Gary] Mhmmm.
- Even if it's just personal,
how are you doing?
You're doing this well.
Great job. I've just
seen that in this environment,
it just seems to just reinforce
so much more than elsewhere.
- [Gary] 'Cause
it's a dictatorship, man.
- [Kenny] Mhmmm.
- This place is a dictatorship.
You're just not going to be able
to win here with negativity.
- [Kenny] Mhmmm.
- You know?
- [Kenny] Yeah.
- Now negativity
should not be confused with
critical and actual feedback.
- [Kenny] Yeah.
- Like if Sally sucks,
she needs to hear it.
In one way or the other.
- [Kenny] Mhmmm.
- And there's only so
much you can sugar coat
you stink at your job.
But, you're absolutely right.
Like, I don't know
where you came from
but I know that no
matter where people come from,
negativity is allowed
because the player
that's deploying
the negativity is
bringing value
in a different way.
I don't play that shit.
- [Kenny] Mhmmm.
- I'm the first one that would
trade my super star player
if he's bringing cancer
to my locker room. First.
I'll send his ass out
for a third round pick,
I don't give a fuck.
- [Kenny] Mhmmm.
- 'Cause you're not gonna win.
And everybody, Lisa,
and Joe, these people know.
That's why.
- [Kenny] Yeah.
- And it's cool, right?
- It's like fun.
- [Kenny] It's awesome.
- You don't dread Sunday.
You know you're not
walking in to any room here
and getting yelled at
for no fucking reason.
- [Kenny] It's a complete 180.
- And I promise
you it will happen,
and it does happen,
those people get fired.
I can't stop
humans from doing shit,
I can just react
to what they do.
And then it becomes
something everybody knows.
- [Kenny] Mhmmm.
- Right.
- [Kenny] Yeah.
- And that becomes the culture.
- Cool, man.
- [Kenny] Awesome.
- Really glad we met.
- Appreciate your time.
- Have a great day.
- You too.
See you at the Town Hall.
- Can't wait.
("Still Waiting" by Jura Kez)